so we're all very, very familiar with Donald
Trump's lack of diplomatics skill.
But today we have a story that takes this
to a new level that actually seems almost
satirical, but in a way it's a refreshing
sort of reality that tells us something arguably
positive about Donald Trump.
And since these things are so few and far
between, I do want to pay some special attention
to it.
You'll remember that not long ago, the g seven
was held in BIA, Ritz France, and we covered
all of the comings and goings.
And one of the things that we're now learning
about are the details of a meeting that Donald
Trump was going to have with the Egyptian
President Abdel Fatah LCC, and according to
the Wall Street Journal, uh, per multiple
people in the room, Donald Trump arrived looking
around for LCC and called out, where's my
favorite dictator?
Which resulted in what was described as stunned
silence in the room.
Apparently a joke, one set of reactions was,
it's not really a joke.
Donald Trump loves dictators, or at least
he loves authoritarians.
This includes his praise of Kim Jong Goin
or doe one, she Putin, Saudi Prince Mohammad
Bin, Solman, Duterte, et cetera.
He's just saying, this guy is my favorite
dictator.
I love dictators and this guy's my favorite
The argument over whether it is a joke though,
I think is the wrong one.
This is an extreme example of a clueless person
not knowing how politics is done yet.
It's more of the same total lack of decorum
and diplomacy that Donald Trump brings to
everything that he does because he's just
ignorant to all of it.
But there is a way in which I'm actually relieved
to hear Donald Trump call one of these authoritarians
a dictator, even if it's not literally the
truth, and I'll explain why in a second.
Now on the, on the fact his LCC, a dictator,
he is often called a dictator.
He's certainly an authoritarian.
He gives the military unchecked power.
He overthrew a democratically elected president
in 2013 in a queue to take power.
He's killed hundreds of protesters.
He's imprisoned tens of thousands of dissidents
of different kinds.
There are allegations of torture of disappearing
journalists and activists and allegations
of abduction.
I mean really just horrible, terrible, terrible
stuff, and he is a violent authoritarian,
if not a dictator.
Now the reason I find this refreshing in some
way from Donald Trump is Trump's already thrown
decorum out the window.
He's thrown diplomacy out the window.
Who Cares about that?
This is just one more example and what is
one more instance of that?
At this point in time, I am glad that Donald
Trump called something at least by what it
might be if it, again, if not literally a
dictator, a dictatorial authoritarian LCC.
When it comes to these authoritarian strong
men, I would prefer that Donald Trump call
them what they are, or at least something
closer to what they are instead of merely
praising them and placating them and working
to please them and complimenting them.
He has already done it with LCC back in 2017
he talked about LCCs doing a great job and
made all sorts of just completely outrageous
statements that ignore the endless, I mean,
just endless human rights abuses that we've
seen, uh, there.
So is it embarrassing for Donald Trump to
walk into a room and say, where's my favorite
dictator?
Of course it's embarrassing.
Is it hilariously an decorous?
If that's a word, of course it is.
But evidence that Trump recognizes dictators
for what they are.
Authoritarians for what they are is slightly
positive.
Is this actual praise of Donald Trump?
Big Picture?
Of course it's not, but it arguably in a way,
it actually makes his praise of authoritarian
dictatorial types.
Even worse, it would be one thing if Trump
doesn't recognize that that's what they are
and just kind of likes the fact that he sees
them as strong figures, Putin, Duterte, all
of them.
It's in a sense worse if he recognizes that
they are dictatorial, dictatorial authoritarians
and still praises them, but he's at least
calling things closer to what they are.
So big picture, it's not like I like Trump
now, but I respect the fact that he actually
entered the room and yelled this out, even
if it is completely outrageous, diplomatically,
because it confirms that Trump recognizes
these people for what they are, the fact that
he likes them, signals of problem with his
moral compass and moral.
The moral compass of Trump is what we'll talk
about next.
But in a sense, he is not as disconnected
from reality as maybe we thought at the end
of last week.
If I'm missing this, if my take on this misses
something else, let me know.
But I actually found it refreshing to hear
Donald Trump refer to LCC, at least buy something
closer to what he is rather than just a great
leader.
The Way Donald Trump refers to most of these,
a dictatorial, dictatorial authoritarians,
let me know what you think.